on the first full day of president
Trump's impeachment defense the Trump
team flips the script on House Democrats
and turns the trial of Donald Trump into
a national broadcast of Democrat
corruption we will examine the wonderful
strategy then the FBI is reportedly
investigating Minnesota representative
Ilhan Omar over claims that she once
married her brother which is definitely
gross and possibly illegal then Pete mu
de jedge shows he's not ready for
primetime and hunter Biden's somehow
incredibly gets into even more trouble
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
whoo boy do we have a lot to get into
today what a roller coaster we went
through yesterday on the Trump
impeachment defense started off very
slow I was sweating I was nervous I
thought it was not going well at all and
then the Trump team just kicked it into
high gear during prime time we will get
to all of it we will get to the very
smart strategy all around but first I've
got to thank our friends over at Robin
Hood with Robin Hood you can invest in
stocks you can invest in options you can
invest in ETFs right from your phone you
can even spend an urn interest
uninvested cash and with fractional
shares you can buy stocks in any amount
including companies like Apple Amazon
and Tesla for as little as one dollar
maybe you can't afford to buy a whole
bunch of shares you can you can buy just
parts of them that is with no Commission
fees or account minimums so whether
you're new to investing and ready to
learn or whether you've got a ton of
experience you should join the 10
million Robin Hood users I love Robin
Hood because I'm actually financially
completely illiterate and what I love
about Robin Hood is it makes it so
simple for me I don't feel like I need
an advanced degree to just invest some
of my money and start start earning a
little bit more go to Noel's dot Robin
Hood com to learn more and claim your
free stock that is Knolls dot Robin Hood
com all investments involve risk this is
not investment advice or recommendation
or a solicitation of any security other
fees may apply visit RB and HD dot CEO
slash fees the free stock program is
subject to certain limitations annual
percentage yield on invested cash is
paid by program banks and is variable
Robin Hood Financial is not a bank but
that is still my recommendation to go
check it out
there was really great stuff from the
Trump team yesterday we'll cut right to
the chase and get to the highlights
then we'll work back and see how that
strategy fits in overall because seen in
light of the really good stuff that the
Trump team gave at the end of the day
the earlier part of their impeachment
defense reads not like a kind of week
open it reads like a threat so it really
starts to kick off well when president
Trump's lawyer
Bondy gets up there and doesn't really
address all the crazy Democratic claims
about Trump all of the the crimes that
aren't actually crimes but are still
simpie chable for some reason according
to the logic of the house impeachment
manager she just ignores that she
doesn't go on defense she doesn't spend
all of her time explaining and
explaining explaining and losing instead
she goes on offense she goes right at
Hunter Biden she goes right at burries
m'a she goes right at Democratic
corruption in the past administration
check it out the typical board member of
these fortune 100 companies we know
they're Titans of their industry they're
highly qualified and as such they're
well compensated even so hunter Biden
was paid significantly more this is how
well he was compensated so hunter Biden
is paid over eighty three thousand
dollars a month while the average
American family of four during that time
each year made less than $54,000 and
that's according to US Census Bureau
during that time and this is what's been
reported about his work on the board The
Washington Post said quote what specific
duties hunter Biden carried out for
Purisima are not fully known end quote
she goes on to say buries mo is so
corrupt that George Kent one of the
people who testified during the house
impeachment investigation said he
intervened to prevent us aid from
co-sponsoring an event with buries me
was so corrupt so the reason this is
important here is because you you don't
just have the Trump team on their heels
you don't just have the Trump team so
far back that they they can't advance
their own arguments they're actually
going for the the Democrats and putting
them on the defensive and then senator
Ted Cruz who I've been hosting this
podcast verdict
with Ted Cruz with all week long he
comes and hits at home in a press gaggle
in one of these breaks senator Cruz went
straight for hunter Biden and put it in
plain terms that everybody including
those who haven't been paying attention
24 hours a day can understand I'm in the
entire proceeding we have heard just at
the beginning of the serious evidence of
corruption involving barista the
Ukrainian natural gas company that paid
hunter Biden Joe Biden's son a million
dollars a year while Joe bought let me
answer I'll answer the question question
let me let me answer the question that
interrupting me please you got it
Maurice my play
paid hunter Biden Joe Biden's son a
million dollars a year while hunter
Biden threatened Ukraine to withhold a
billion dollars in aid unless and until
they fired the prosecutor investigating
his son Joe Biden threatened Joe Biden
is vice president United States and we
just saw a video which I would encourage
every news outlet here to actually show
the video of Joe Biden bragging how he
told the president of Ukraine that he
was gonna cut off a billion dollars he
was gonna block a billion dollars in
foreign aid to Ukraine unless they fired
the prosecutor and in Joe Biden's own
words son of a [ __ ]
they fired the guy this was a strategy
that senator Cruz had previewed on our
our podcast earlier this week he said
you've got to make Purisima you've got
to make the Biden's the center of this
whole thing it worked it was over the
target you know I think Pam Bondi did a
good job but I think senator Cruz did a
better job Cruz drove these reporters so
crazy that at one point he actually made
one of them suggest throwing his nine
and eleven year-old children in prison
none of the presidents attorneys
mentioned one single possible client
that harbor Joe Biden are accused of
basically 100 Biden got a job as vice
president if that's a crime I mean you
shouldn't have your children be in
prison
my children are nine and eleven I'm
sorry that you want to throw a
nine-year-old in prison but at this
point but my third grader plays
basketball and softball at her school so
so stop playing the nasty note no stop
playing than that nasty Washington game
that's how you know the senator Cruz is
over the target he handled it very well
but I just love it these mainstream
media hacks these absolute liberal
propagandists they get so angry that
hunting that senator Cruz has identified
the real key in the impeachment trial
which is not answering all this BS from
the Democrats but actually going after
their whole corruption which was at the
center of the phone call to get the
investigation that got us the
impeachment in the first place right go
right back to the heart of it all the
the mainstream media liberal hacks were
so upset about this they decide they're
gonna threaten Ted Cruz's daughters and
say they should be thrown in prison
beautiful and and senator Cruz handled
it very very well wasn't just hunter
Biden either the Trump legal team also
went after this so-called whistleblower
so you had in this case Patrick Philbin
the deputy counsel to the president when
he was making his presentation in the
impeachment trial he decided to focus in
on the so-called whistleblower because I
know it's it's so convoluted it's been
so insane how this impeachment forest
began but let's remember it began when
President Trump had a phone call with
the president of Ukraine and in that
phone call he suggested some
investigations into corruption the
allegation then the Democrats made was
the President Trump was withholding
military aid until Ukraine agreed to
investigate corruption that involved Joe
Biden and this was a big deal because
Joe Biden is running against President
Trump in 2020 although
increasingly it's looking like he's not
gonna get the nomination of his party
anyway so that's how it all began there
was a so-called whistleblower who heard
this phone call with Ukraine and made a
big deal out of it and that's how we got
impeachment so so Patrick fill Ben the
this lawyer for the president starts
asking about this whistleblower who is
this guy if he's at the heart of this
whole thing why don't we know anything
about him here's philbin whistleblower
who we haven't heard that much about who
started all this the whistleblower we
know from a letter that the Inspector
General of the intelligence community
sent that he thought that the
whistleblower had political bias we
don't know exactly what the political
bias was because the Inspector General
testified in the House committees in an
executive session and that transcript is
still secret
it wasn't transmitted up to the House
Judiciary Committee we haven't seen it
we don't know what's in it we don't know
what he was asked and what he revealed
about the whistleblower then you would
think that before in going forward with
an impeachment proceeding against the
President of the United States that you
would want to find out something about
the complainant that had started all
because motivations bias reasons for
wanting to bring this complaint could be
relevant yes thank you
exactly that's right that's right
that's what this is about so Patrick
Philbin Pam Bondi they are putting the
Democrats on their heels and then
Philbin by the way he tees it up he says
we why are we asking questions about the
whistleblower and then he starts to go
after him with details because we all
have a pretty good sense of who this
whistleblower is seems like he had
connections to Joe Biden seems like he
was leaking out of the intelligence
community
and Philbin goes right for him recent
reports public reports suggest that
potentially the whistleblower was in
telecommunications community staffer who
worked with then Vice President Biden on
Ukraine matters which if true would
suggest an even greater reason for
wanting to know about potential bias or
motive for the whistleblower that's
right
so he actually starts doing it he says
we need to start asking questions and
then he asks the questions we need to
start looking into this whistleblower
then he starts looking into the
whistleblower we need much more of this
in this impeachment trial this is
actually president Trump style this is
the sort of thing that President Trump
does and will actually see an example of
that in a little bit but he should make
sure that his whole legal team adopts
this style too it's very very effective
I have to admit I was terrified when
these defenses started out today you
know Ken Starr the famous investigator
from the Clinton impeachment he was the
first person on Trump's legal team to
make a presentation and I thought I
thought it was a little weak I thought
if this is all we're gonna get
from the Trump legal defense he's
actually in a lot of trouble but when
you look at Ken Starr's opening
arguments in the light of the later
arguments which go right after hunter
Biden go right after the whistleblower
then you see there was actually a
brilliant strategy here in Starr's
opening arguments because his arguments
they played almost like a law school
lecture they played almost sort of
philosophical taken out of context but
when you look at them in context they
were a threat to Democrats we'll get to
that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over at Daniels you know how
much I love Daniels how you carry your
personal items can make you look
prepared adult mature like you know what
you're doing or like a
slot are you still carrying around some
old college backpack when you go to work
you show up at your job and it's like
your mother packed your backpack for you
if so grow up kids come on I'm sorry I
know this is tough love but you need it
get a briefcase and when you get a
briefcase there's only one choice
Daniels Daniels based in New York City
makes a leather briefcases for the
modern professional they're just
magnificent I've had a lot of really
nice briefcases in my life of Gundams
hand-me-downs and gifts and stuff
Daniel's is my favorite by far they have
a really really high-quality durable
Italian leather briefcases
they there is no nicer leather than
Italian leather it's so beautiful the
size is perfect it's simple it's it's
not flashy it's just got really really
elegant design I simply love mine this
week my listeners can get fifty dollars
off their Daniels briefcase at Daniel's
a NYC comm by using the promo code
Michael mi CH AE l get it now I cannot
recommend this more highly fifty bucks
off one of your one of their leather
briefcases Plus free shipping free
returns and free exchanges if you don't
like it you're gonna love it
Daniel's NYC comm promo code Michael mi
CH AE L for $50 off a handcrafted
high-quality leather briefcase with free
shipping you can start looking like a
professional today do it so I was
terrified when it started out then I
realized Ken store knows what he's doing
should have known it in the first place
but it was a really subtle but effective
argument so Ken Starr begins and he
points out there's no crimes Trump
didn't commit any crimes the articles of
impeachment don't even say that he
committed crimes then he gets to the
danger of this impeachment he even
describes the time that we're living in
as the age of impeachment here he is
the Senate is being called to sit as the
high court of impeachment all too
frequently indeed we're living in what I
think can aptly be described as the age
of impeachment in the house resolution
after resolution
month after month has called for the
president's impeachment how did we get
here
yet here at home and the world's longest
standing constitutional republic instead
of a once in a century phenomenon which
it had been presidential impeachment has
become a weapon to be wielded against
one's political opponent absolutely
right a great point a great point the
left is accusing ken starr of hypocrisy
because he says how did we get to this
point where we're living in the age of
impeachment and what the left is saying
is we got here because of you you're the
guy who impeached Clinton so it's your
fault how dare you what what rank
hypocrisy it's not hypocrisy it's
experience it ken starr is speaking with
some credibility here he's saying look I
was involved in the Clinton impeachment
I was brought in as this investigator
but now we're doing this so regularly
it's become merely a political tool it's
not being used in the way that the
founders and framers of our Constitution
wanted it to so what's happening here is
its reopening some of the impeachment
trial some of the impeachment of Bill
Clinton it's reminding people of the
impeachment of Bill Clinton if that was
all they were doing it would be very
stupid strategy because it would be just
restocking those resentments getting
Democrats to remember how much they
hated the Clinton impeachment getting
them more ready to go after Trump in
this impeachment but that's not what it
was doing what this opening did was get
all of that out of the way and set the
stage of these constant impeachments as
a real danger to the Republic because
we're now just going to be living in a
system where the Congress throws out
whatever president it doesn't like
that's not the system that our founders
wanted but that's the system we're
getting into now Ken Starr says that
would be a very bad thing in fact he
goes so far as to say that impeachment
is hell
like war impeachment is hell or at least
presidential impeachment is hell those
of us who live through the Clinton
impeachment including members of this
body full well understand that a
presidential impeachment is tantamount
to domestic war out of it thankfully
protected by our beloved First Amendment
a war of words and a war of ideas but
it's filled with acrimony and it divides
the country like nothing else those of
us who live through the Clinton
impeachment month understand that at a
deep and personal way it's hell it's
like war it divides the country and we
are in the age of impeachment but do we
have to be that's the question that Ken
Starr is leaving on the table do we have
to be because there's a little bit of a
cause-and-effect here right it is true
that impeachment divides the country but
impeachment also comes only during
periods of great division
so the first impeachment we had was of
President Andrew Johnson that was in
1868 now did did the impeachment of
Andrew Johnson caused the division in
the country no we had just come out of
the Civil War I mean it was the greatest
division you could possibly have and the
impeachment was a result of that
division next impeachment we have or
near impeachment we have of Richard
Nixon was in 1974 did Richard Nixon
divide the country no the country was
terribly divided on the heels of the
1960s and the rise of radical left ISM
in the Cold War
next impeachment we have 1998
that's the impeachment of Bill Clinton
who perjured himself and will had his
law license suspended because of what he
did we're pretty divided in the 90s to I
mean the 90s was that prime era of
political correctness the parties were
really starting to separate they were
really starting to dig into what they
believed and
and now we have another impeachment in
2019 so this is getting faster and
faster or are we divided as a country
because Trump got impeached no Trump got
impeached because we're divided as a
country but it does further divide the
country that's why you're seeing it
speed up now this was a great way for
the Trump legal team to stave off some
criticism stave off criticism that they
didn't want to hear witnesses that they
were just trying to dodge impeachment
that they were using Ken Starr as a
lawyer in the first place they addressed
all of the the criticisms that could be
thrown at them and they also sent a
threat they sent a message here which
was if you want this fight Democrats if
you're gonna try to remove a duly
elected president for total BS then
we're gonna do it to you because
impeachment is hell impeachment is like
war impeachment divides the country and
we're not going to give it up without a
fight if you want this hell we will
engage in that hell with you you see it
on them on the microscale when it comes
to the witnesses right the Democrats
have all they want is to call former
National Security Advisor john bolton to
testify because they think john Bolton's
got dirt on trump and the threat here i
think was you call john bolton we call
hunter biden you really want to play
this game you want to talk to john
bolton so bad that's fine we'll drag joe
biden's degenerate corrupt son in front
of national television on the senate and
have him spout off all that corrupt
things he's done with other corrupt
people from the obama administration you
really want that on the on the macro
level the threat implied here was you
remove our guy from office over bs guess
what we're gonna do the first chance we
get the first chance there's a Democrat
in office and a Republican Congress and
hopefully a Republican Senate that guy's
gone not because it's right but because
that's the political situation that you
Democrats have forced us into because
you have shredded the Constitution and
we have to live in the new people
reality because we can't unilaterally
disarm that's the threat that's being
implied here and it did a whole lot to
turn around the perception of President
Trump's defense this is the first day
that Trump gets to defend himself right
yet a whole week of Democrat accusations
from the house impeachment managers now
he defends himself I think they did a
very good job and I think the the
strengths of these lawyers balanced each
other out very very well because they
were coming into this today with a big
leak there was this big leak to the New
York Times from former national security
adviser John Bolton's forthcoming memoir
that said that Trump tied military aid
in Ukraine to the investigation of Joe
Biden which by the way would be
perfectly fine if it did but it created
a whole lot of headlines here right so
that's what they were going into and as
a result of that leak to the New York
Times obviously highly coordinated to
maximize damage to president Trump's
impeachment trial to try to extend this
thing so that Democrats can go on a
fishing expedition because Democrats
have come up empty so far three years
later they got nothing and it had its
intended effect because the squishy
Republican senators like Mitt Romney
came out and said yeah we want to hear
more witnesses to be fair in John
Bolton's defense this is not John
Bolton's fault look he put it in the
book maybe he should have waited to
publish the book
maybe the publisher is trying to juice
book sales but john bolton ran this by
the white house he sent a copy of this
to the white house this is on the
squishy senators chief among them a mitt
romney and mitt romney is now suggesting
that he will vote to hear more witnesses
to drag this impeachment trial out into
the foreseeable future areas it's
increasingly apparent that it would be
important to hear from john bolton
III of course will make a final decision
on witnesses after we've heard from not
only the prosecution but also the
defense but i think at this stage it's
pretty fair to say that john bolton has
a
relevant testimony I think it's
increasingly likely that other
Republicans will will join those of us
who think we should hear from John
Bolton uh Mitt Romney why why do you
have to be Mitt Romney I knew I said
this yesterday I said I'm gonna be here
doing the verdict with Ted Cruz podcast
as long as we see impeachment going and
so my chances of returning home to Los
Angeles rested on Mitt Romney not being
a jerk so I might as well start looking
for apartments now looks like I was
right Susan Collins another squishy
senator she's in Maine
she's also signalling that she's in
favor of witnesses Susan Collins is up
for re-election this year and she
already has Trump support Maine went
three electoral votes out of four for
Hillary Clinton in 2016 so it's a very
delicate situation for Susan Collins
probably she has to vote for more
witnesses then you've got another
squishy senator Lisa Murkowski in Alaska
Lisa Murkowski is not up for re-election
until 2022 so she can do whatever she
wants and I think probably she would
prefer to call witnesses it's probably
the safer move for a moderate senator
like her Lamar Alexander from Tennessee
another moderate he's retiring from the
Senate he doesn't Gary's got nothing to
lose he has no reason not to do what he
wants he's got no reason to try to
preserve his legacy the safe choice for
him probably to call witnesses so right
now if nothing changes it's looking like
we might get witnesses and we might get
a longer impeachment trial it is going
to be up to these guys these four
senators maybe some others could be
swayed to so today
Trump's big defense date trump offer a
very strong defense right out the gate
it was strong it was strong because it
was an offense started out by setting
the stage then he went for the jugular
it should all be offense from here on it
should all be hunter Biden and burries
m'a and the whistleblower it should be
all pressure on Democrats Ronald Reagan
used to say when you're explaining
you're losing so when you're defending
yourself when you're on your heels
you're losing
Queen Elizabeth has a phrase that she's
reportedly fond of saying which has
never complained never explain you're
always pushing what you want forward
Trump team did that today a trump does
this strategy personally he actually
just did it with regard to Ilhan Omar
who may have married her brother yuck
we'll get to that in a second we'll get
to why people judge is just absolutely
blowing it and he's not ready for
primetime and we will get to hunter
Biden somehow getting into even more
trouble and if this impeachment defense
from President Trump keeps going the way
it's going he's gonna be in even more
trouble soon before we get to that I
want to talk about the pro-life cause
while the pro-abortion activists shout
their abortions on national television
and refer to preborn babies as parasites
pro-lifers have fought back all of us at
the Daily wire have spoken out in
defense of life last year ben shapiro
dressed crowd of a hundred thousand at
the March for Life in Washington DC and
you know what happened as a result of
that our advertisers were targeted by
left-wing media operatives we lost a lot
of revenue as a result they were trying
to shut us down and shut us up this is a
constant battle to protect pro-life
advocacy from the forces pushing
abortion live action has experienced the
same thing live action is one of the
most important voices in the pro-life
movement I personally support live
action and you should too you know they
have they have helped to expose Planned
Parenthood and other abortion clinics
for the horrific climbs crimes rather
that they commit pro-abortion activists
have targeted live action and censored
them on social media platforms when they
don't succeed in kicking them off
altogether and that's why our daily
wire.com members are so important your
membership helps keep our cameras on and
our microphones turned up even when the
left is pressuring our sponsors you keep
our pro-life message from being canceled
and from now until January 1st a portion
of any daily wire.com membership will be
donated to live action with promo code
live action easy enough to remember so
join daily wired.com and make your
pro-life voice heard head on over to
daily wire.com we'll be right back with
a lot more
never explain always be pushing your
agenda always be pushing the stories
that you want to see president Trump
knows this implicitly right that's how
he's been a tabloid star a media
manipulator for 40 years now I mean
since the 80s really since the late 70s
you're seeing this in a particular news
story right now which involves Minnesota
representative Ilhan Omar one of a
o'seas squad there have been stories
going around since 2016-2017 that Ilhan
Omar married her brother now it's not
quite as gross as it seems I guess the
allegation is not that she married her
brother because she fell in love with
him but that she married her brother to
commit immigration fraud to get some
kind of immigration advantage we don't
know if that's true we don't know what
sort of advantage it would be that has
just been the allegation and it's come
from multiple sources and the question
is why is nobody investigating this well
it seems someone now is investigating it
two FBI agents held an hours-long
meeting in Minnesota back in October
with a concerned party whoever that is
handing over a bunch of documents
regarding Ilhan Omar's 2009 marriage to
Achmed Noor Saeed Elmi regarding whether
or not she married her brother so people
are investigating this now this is
according to multiple sources President
Trump was asked about it and instead of
playing defense and playing it safe and
playing it cautious he decided to blare
that headline all over the world here he
is well there's a lot of talk about the
fact that she was married to her brother
I know nothing about it I hear she was
married to her brother you're asking me
a question about it
I don't know but I'm sure that somebody
would be looking at that I love this
look a lot of people are talking about
the fact that Ilhan Omar married her
brother I like that he phrases it as the
fact that Ilhan Omar marries her brother
but we don't know we don't I don't know
anything about that I don't know
anything about the very fact that Ilan
Omar married her brother which many
people are talking about Trump does this
all the time I mean it is it is one of
the most often used rhetorical
strategies he has but it's very
effective because all you hear from this
because he repeats it multiple times is
Ilhan Omar married her brother the fact
that Ilhan Omar married her brother by
the way we don't know that it's affect
yet there's just a lot of evidence for
it and it's pretty weird that no one's
investigated it just to give you a
little sense of whether or not it's true
here's here's just a glimpse at the
timeline of her marital life so 1982
Ilhan Omar is born in Somalia she comes
to Minneapolis with her family in 1997
then five years later when Ilhan Omar is
19 years old she marries a guy named
Achmed here see who is 22 in her faith
tradition but not legally so they're not
legally married 2008 so six years after
they get married in the faith tradition
Omar and heresee have two kids and they
divorce in their faith tradition one
year later
Ilhan Omar 26 years old at this point
marries Achmed nor Saeed Elmi who's only
23 years old 3 years younger then two
years after that
Ilhan Omar and L me end their
relationship divorce in their faith
tradition and do not legally get
divorced until 2017 so this is pretty
weird right
Ilhan Omar marries a guy but not legally
then they have two kids and six years
later all of a sudden they separate but
they were never legally married so they
don't get legally divorced then a year
later she marries this random guy and
then two years later they divorce in
their faith tradition but for some
reason they stay legally married for
another six years but then in 2012 so
one year after Omar and L me separate
but they did still don't get divorced
for a lot of years Omar and here's he
get back together and they have a third
child together for the next few years
Ilhan Omar is filing joint tax returns
with this guy here see but she's still
legally married to this other guy l me
then
Oumar becomes a big public figure and
things start to get a little dicey 2016
she's elected to the Minnesota House
2017 she legally divorces Elmi who is
possibly her brother we don't know who
the guy is
and then in 2018 she legally marries
here see the father of her three
children who she's been with for a very
very long time and then she's elected to
Congress nothing about this timeline
makes sense and it does seem to be very
possible that it's a case of immigration
fraud this needs to be investigated this
needs to be investigated in particular
because she's a rising star in the
Democratic Party and she has absolutely
Oh Diaz political views and she referred
to the September 11th attacks as some
people did something and she giggled
well talking about al-qaeda and
Hezbollah and she just her views are
just simply disgusting and repugnant so
on a political angle we should really go
after this this lady that's just
politics though you know we go after
everybody on the left in politics as a
matter of the law seems like this merits
an investigation more generally
conservatives need to be on the
offensive we need to put the Democrats
on their toes the best defense is a good
offense now the Trump that the Trump
team is doing a good job of this I hope
they keep it up because it's a good
start president Trump almost certainly
won't be removed from office the odds of
that are extremely low but this could
drag on for weeks and weeks and weeks
and who knows what that will mean for
2020 in politics anything happens and
speaking of 2020 and speaking of blowing
it
Pete mu de jedge is absolutely
collapsing in his campaign he was once
the bright young star he was the one
surging he had all the momentum that
momentum has kind of cratered at this
point Bernie Sanders is at the top of
the polls in Iowa and New Hampshire
multiple polls Pete Budaj edge appears
to be deflating just like Elizabeth
Warren it just seems like he's not ready
for primetime a great example of this he
was asked in a town hall the other night
by a pro-life democrat if he would
welcome her into the party and he danced
around the question and he
wouldn't give a straight answer and he
basically said yeah no of course we can
agree to disagree as long as you agree
with me and this woman who asked the
question wouldn't let him get away with
it she said this Democratic party
platform specifically excludes pro-life
democrats like me would you represent a
democratic party that makes room and
includes pro lifers like me or are you
gonna just absolutely exclude my views
on abortion my views as a woman my views
as somebody who thinks we should protect
life and Pete Buddha judge says
absolutely or out of the party the
Democratic platform contains language
that basically says that we don't belong
we have no part in the party because it
says abortion should be legal up to nine
months the government should pay for it
and there's nothing that says that
people have by diversity of views on
this issue should be included in the
party in 1996 and I guess several years
after that there was a language in the
Democratic platform that said that we
understand that people have very
differing views on this issue but we are
a big tent party that includes everybody
and so therefore we welcome you people
like me into the party so we can work on
issues that we agree on so I my question
was to youth would you be open to
language like that and that the
democratic pipe platform that really did
say that our party is diverse and
inclusive and we want everybody well I
support the position of my party that
this kind of medical care needs to be
available to everyone and I support the
Roe versus Wade framework that holds
that early in pregnancy there are very
few restrictions and late in pregnancy
there are very few exceptions and again
the best I can offer is that we may
disagree on that very important issue
and hopefully we will be able to partner
on other issues terrible answer
regardless of your views of abortion
absolutely terrible answer and a
terrible look you know that the
Democratic Party is always projecting so
they always because they're so obsessed
with race they call everyone else
racists and because they are so obsessed
with sex they call everybody else sexist
they have a problem in this election
cycle which is that they've already
kicked out all of the racial minority
candidates so now it's just a bunch of
white people not a good look makes them
look pretty hypocritical on racial
issues they've got another issue here
which just from a just from a visual
perspective is not a great look for
Democrats you've got this guy Pete Budaj
telling this woman who is a Democrat
that she's no longer welcome in the
party because she opposes abortion but
the Democrats whole argument on abortion
is that in order to support women you
have to be pro-abortion that all women
love abortion that woman's rights are
now actually just a synonym for abortion
according to the modern left and yet
here's this woman right who says
actually actually mayor Pete I know that
you think you're gonna speak for all the
women but I'm a woman and I oppose
abortion so that's okay right and he
says absolutely not you're out of the
party you are not in my party you do not
speak for women I speak for women me
Pete Buddha judge not you a woman just a
dumb answer he should have known better
than that he's a pretty slick young
politician but it's just a reminder he's
not ready for primetime and he's not
ready on the sexual issues he's not he's
not really ready either in terms of
relating to ordinary people he just
doesn't have it so very few politicians
actually watch sports but a lot of them
try to talk about sports disingenuously
because they think that that's a good
way to relate to the common man
and so people judge was asked about the
death of Kobe Bryant the tragic
helicopter crash and PPO judge said oh
well you know it was just so well he'll
be remembered for what he did on the
field as well as what he did off the
field because apparently Peabody judge
doesn't realize Kobe Bryant plays
basketball which is not played on a
field here he is there are millions of
people not just in Los Angeles but
around the world right now mourning
because they were inspired by what he
did on the field what he meant off the
field okay
so either Pete Budaj edge doesn't know
that Kobe Bryant
my basketball and I gotta at least hope
that that Buddha judge knows that Kobe
play basketball or he just doesn't know
anything about basketball because he
thinks it's played on a field rather
than a court you've got to know these
things okay or you got a not pretend to
know these things you got to not pretend
I mean the pandering is just so tedious
when it when it comes to Buddha judge we
don't know who this guy is he's a
completely new figure on the national
scene and the the mask is slipping a
little bit he's he's changing his views
he's a radical one days a moderate the
other day he's the everyman one day he's
this elite moralist who's going to
preach to you on the other day he just
doesn't know who he is he's just just
not ready for primetime and that
actually gets to a story coming out from
Washington Post and ABC News there's a
new poll that was released on Monday
released yesterday found the President
Trump is now in a better position
against nearly every 2020 democratic
competitor as a result of impeachment
and the impeachment trial now and
possibly the impeachment vote so the
conclusion that all of these political
analysts are reaching is that
impeachment has been good for Trump and
that's why Trump is doing better against
all the Democrats now which may well be
true I think probably impeachment has
been good for Trump but the part that
all of the political analysts are
ignoring is the Democratic candidates
themselves because the the other thing
that's happened in the past few months
other than the impeachment trial is that
we've gotten to see a lot more of these
Democratic candidates and I strongly
suspect the more we see of these
candidates the less we like them the
less everybody likes them the less the
Democratic primary voters like them they
seem the Democratic primary voters seem
pretty pretty demoralized you see this
from guys like Van Jones Democratic
analyst who says gosh the people who
show up to these debates are not ready
to beat Donald Trump you know the more
we see a Budaj edge the worse is numbers
get the same is true of Warren the same
is true
of Joe Biden even even Joe Biden Joe
Biden's been around forever I think he's
been in politics for 50 years but Joe
Biden hasn't really been in the arena
since 2008 he ran for president 2008 he
got knocked around a bunch then he got a
really soft easy job under Obama he was
the vice president vice president is not
a controversial position to be in so his
approval numbers went up and then he
didn't run in 2016 so his approval
numbers didn't get a hit we forgot who
Joe Biden was and ever since he's been
out on the campaign trail his numbers
keep dipping the only person that this
isn't true of is Bernie Sanders because
Bernie was in the spotlight last time he
was in the arena in 2016
he's probably the toughest of these
candidates and that's probably why his
numbers are going up in Iowa and New
Hampshire turning gears from people who
were approaching 80 years old we need to
go back down to the youth of the
Democratic Party in the youth of the
left there was a tweet that was sent out
from David hog the the most prominent of
the teen gun control activists this
tweet has gone viral and I read it
because it shows so much about the
modern Left this is this is the tweet
quote this is a tweet for for the
founders of the gun violence protection
prevention movement started centuries
ago by almost entirely black brown and
indigenous LGBTQ women and non-binary
people that never got on the news or in
most history books we may not know all
your names but thank you I actually want
to defend David hog for a moment but
obviously that's that statement is
ridiculous first of all I don't think
extorting but getting getting on the
news I don't think TV news existed
centuries ago I'm not sure how he would
know that the founders of the gun
violence prevention movement were almost
entirely black brown and indigenous
LGBTQ women and non-binary people that
seems like a really really niche group
of people to start the gun violence
prevention movement particularly
considering the fact that most early gun
control was actually specific
anti-black and that all of the great
civil rights leaders from emancipation
onward made a big point to arm
themselves because they were the victims
of systemic oppression never mind all of
that obviously it's an absurd tweet but
I want to defend David hog because of
how absurd this tweet is first of all
he's a freshman in college and he
doesn't know anything about anything
freshmen in college don't know anything
imagine if you were a celebrity when you
were 18 years old this is why teenagers
should not be celebrities child stars
tend not to turn out terribly well
teenagers should not be celebrities it
is not good for them it's not good for
anybody else also in david hogs defense
david hog is a freshman at Harvard he
got accepted into Harvard because of his
activism he may have learned this
nonsense in a classroom at Harvard he'd
be much more likely to learn this stuff
in a classroom at Harvard than he would
at a community college because the halls
of elite universities have become
totally radicalized maybe not totally
maybe that's extreme but nearly totally
I mean incredibly radicalized and and
turned into tools of political ideology
the Academy is so hopelessly ideological
now that facts are often abandoned in
favor of political fantasies like the
idea that the gun violence prevention
movement whatever that is was started by
black indigenous LGBT non-binary people
of color in the 18th century that we'd
crazy but that's not david hogs fault
not entirely at least when teenagers do
and say stupid things they're just doing
what teenagers do that's pretty much the
definition of a teenager is doing and
saying stupid things the real problem
here is the teachers who teach them this
nonsense in the first place the fact
that really now the inmates are running
the asylum and speaking of people who
are behaving badly hunter Biden is now
in even more trouble the New York Post
just caught hunter Biden and his
pregnant wife Melissa
fooling around Beverly Hills in $130,000
Porsche this was after they finished
their $90 brunch at a restaurant owned
by chef Shawn George celebrity chef and
this is before they were returning to
their 3.8 million dollar Hollywood Hills
mansion that they're paying $12,000 per
month for all well hunter Biden is
refusing to pay child support to an
ex-girlfriend of his for another kid he
just had out of wedlock I don't even
mean to beat up on on hunter Biden he is
certainly a degenerate but he seems like
a very troubled guy and I have no
interest in beating up on him I'll go
after his father I don't really care
about going after him but imagine if
this were Don jr. imagine if this were
any Republican imagine the headlines
imagine the politicians talking about it
and that's how the Left wins the left
wins because they never play defense
they always play offense they are always
they'll they'll defend every absurd
thing they ever say they will double
down on every absurd thing they will
accuse you of things that you've never
done they'll pluck them out of thin air
the Russia conspiracy tax evasion this
Ukraine hoax
they'll just pluck in people they're
actually now impeaching the president
without a crime two articles of
impeachment zero crimes in them but they
don't care because the left is always on
offense and we play it safe we have a
great economy a great I mean record high
economy record low unemployment record
piece abroad the fact that we just
according to the Left waged World War
three and then I guess won World War
three in the killing of sulemani with
Iran retaliating in a weak way it ended
that conflict amazing stuff we've we've
gotten China to concede on trade deals
we've just it's been so good that the
2020 election should be a blowout and
yet it's close and the only reason it's
close is because the left is always
playing offense and we are always
playing it safe we are right now in
in 2020 looking at a race where the
incumbent very successful president is
running against an old communist a
radical liar a small-town mayor and an
empty suit whose teeth literally fall
out of his mouth during debates and it's
closed it's closed because we don't get
aggressive and the Trump team today has
signaled that they're going to get
aggressive in this impeachment we should
extend that strategy all the way through
2020 all the way through the way that we
wage politics all right that's our show
we got a lot more to get to but hey
we're at a time come back to the Michael
Nolt show tomorrow in the meantime I am
Michael Knowles see you then
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode and frankly
even if you didn't don't forget to
subscribe and if you want to help spread
the word please give us a five star
review and tell your friends to
subscribe we're available on Apple
podcasts Spotify and wherever else you
listen to podcasts also be sure to check
out the other daily wire podcasts
including the Ben Shapiro show the
Andrew Clavin show and the Matt Walsh
show the Michael Noel's show is produced
by Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer Robin Anderson hair
and makeup Jessa alvera production
assistants McKenna Waters and Ryan love
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]